welcome to the sixth video of the D for
repertoire series and this is the first
video to deal with black setups starting
with an ID of six on in this case we'll
be talking about the nimzo-indian um
because um in order to get the
repertoire complete as a whole it is
essential to play a second c4 here as
already shown in the previous videos if
you go Knight f3 which is perfectly okay
you know from a general point of view it
simply doesn't fit within the repertoire
against the Queen's Gambit and also it
won't fit with the suggestions against
Benoni and Kings Indian setup so you
need to go our c4 and then because we'll
be dealing with the names over here c6
of course and now on it's essential
really for the whole repertoire to go on
Knight c3 the main point is if black now
switches back to a a Queen's Gambit with
with d5 that you have to exchange
variation available as shown in the
previous videos of things Isis with your
form um also if black now switch respect
to to mean only with c5 we still get the
whole on range of lines available with
involving F for my F through Y our other
lines that don't commit a knight to f3
so of course most of the time black will
go for the names own and this is no no
big surprise because of course the
nearness um yeah maybe the most popular
way of dealing with one d form of course
only used in connection with other
openings like
you know the Queen's Gambit of white
goes on Ida three or move via move to
yeah it's a very solid defense so you
cannot expect to to get the huge opening
advantage but it's still interesting to
to try to fight the nerves oh well in
direct fashion so to say because the
main idea of course of this opening is
to um well at least at the beginning try
to establish some control over a fall
with pieces so the first gram it's now
controlled by the night so if for
immediately is prevented um of course
black cannot do without any part in the
center but mostly he will delay of
occupying the pawn with centers to a
suitable moment when White has some
already committed somehow in connection
with the whole repertoire as mentioned
it is essential to to allow the names oh
but what you actually play on the move
form this basically yeah you're free
there to choose whatever variation you
like because once you get them you don't
have much transpositional possibilities
um the main moves here the moves that
are played most often um I actually
Queen c2 and I guess I guess III which
are perfectly okay if you like those
lines you can investigate them
especially Queen c2 might attract people
who like to avoid them the double pawns
on c3 and it's a very popular line but
it's it's not really fitting into the
the whole concept of this repertoire
which is basically aim to you have to
take
to take the center and play in an
aggressive fashion with Queen c2 very
often white gets behind in development
this is not really serious but you start
to say trade long term factors here for
slide of course slight short-term
problems because you're not developed
very good for instance of black castles
a3 Bishop takes Queen takes a line that
has become popular recently is d5 and I
just want to make you example them to
get the idea here white takes for
instance which is maybe not the best
move black might go for this Queen c2 85
and now blacks next move from will be c5
Bishop a5 black gets some initiative
here you get the bishop pair in you
return for white and a healthy structure
but it's it's not an opening in which
you can well attack black so to say you
don't have any any much aggressive
possibilities so while this is okay if
you know what you're doing I recommend a
different approach and move for and this
move is for f3 which is some really
respectable line but it's it's not
played that often but if you look at
players who actually use this move in
the past you you get almost the whole
list yeah the whole the whole top of the
ranking list or so to say you find games
of world champion of the Cheyenne and or
some games but kramnik sheer off have an
area Bluffs also very strong player uses
this line regularly the idea of f3 of
courses is very direct it immediately
takes care about the e4 square which is
some appeal of this line I think so it's
really battling blacks main idea
at the first possible moment Liguria
needs to watch out here because if white
gets into play if or without any other
concessions and we were simply good for
him of course f3 it's also a
disadvantage it's not a developing move
and it's also not the nicest proof for
the night on g1 but let's have a look at
some specific lines um the main move
here it's played really by far it's by
far the most popular option as a d5 by
black but let's take a look first at two
other side lines that are played um
first one I'd like to briefly look at at
c5 and okay white advances upon and
follows up with a form just have a quick
look at the type of position that might
come up if black doesn't take on c3 em
for instance if he castles white grabs
the center with a four and continues
with noisy to actually intending to
recapture with the knight on c3 and one
possibility could be taking on d5 CD 5
now b5 to get some play on the Queen
side and then white goes not g3 with
further play along the lines of Bishop
e2 castles and with some preparation you
might go Bishop g5 to pin the knight on
f6 and maybe even f45 at some point it's
it's quite an aggressive set of what is
a nice center with pawns on d5 34 and I
think white is slightly better here um
they're formed like very often captures
on t3 and you get a structure which is
often looking like this of course you
have to double pawn but it's not a pawn
that black in attack easily because the
C fineness is closed
obviously this position would be
entirely different if black pawn would
be on c7 and set of c5
cause when c7 he would have chances to
place his six at some point taking and
then pressurizing on the C file this is
not possible here anymore and here very
often you get positions which look a
little bit like this white will get some
lay on the kingside going and he just
has a huge space advantage I think this
kind of position is very difficult for
black to play might be okay with very
exact play but it's it's not not not
nice to play you have such a huge
disadvantage in space um this very often
happen if that happens if black doesn't
know really specific theory here another
option on mu for is move castles
actually and this is the kind of thing
you'll get by two kinds of players I
think very strong ones and rather weak
ones because weak once met don't know
what they're doing with this move and
strong ones might have a specific idea
the thing here is if white plays d4 now
which looks very logical actually this
moves is a bit problematic it doesn't
have the best reputation at the moment
maybe there are some ways to improve the
play for white but um the d5 right now
looks very fine for black the problem
actually is that well why does a
somewhat underdeveloped of course he
just has got the knight out and all
those pieces on the King side are not
not playing yet and very often you get
positions laggy five night retreats and
then a black goes for quick f6 and white
cannot really deal properly with this
because of the bad development so um at
this point actually the correct move at
the moment seems to be to play a three
to directly get the bishop black of
course needs to take now B takes and
this is a position
which can also rise of course after for
a three the orders image variation but
this is a kind of specific form of this
because black has already castles with
this duel this is actually unusual to do
so early it's Bob even in the a3 move
order but it's it's it's a bit unusual
and the reason is that at this position
exactly here I think black needs to
really needs to play the next move
otherwise he get problems black needs to
play a 98 here and I think this is a
move that I don't know most let's say
weaker players wouldn't wouldn't play
they are more likely to play a move like
b6 or c5 or d5 and all this moves let's
for example say b6 um can be answered
with Bishop g5 and this is a absolutely
annoying pin which is very hard to break
because black doesn't want to play H is
at age 6 mg 5 and this is almost an
automatic game for white to go you form
which should be 392 and then f4 castles
of course and this is just an automatic
attack so black needs to need to retreat
here and then you grab the center with
your form so I'm try to make use of the
arrows it's a bit much the general idea
here I just show a couple of moves just
to get an objective set up like this
going u5 and this is very aggressive
towards the Kings side Knight may be
ready to go to g5 Bishop pointing to h7
of course it's not all a bed of roses
for whites is because you see the red
marks yeah you haven't forgot a very
very bad Queen side so it's it's
double-edged but it's interesting to
play and I think quite dangerous for
black one thing you need to be aware of
because you might say okay this looks
very risky at the moment a lot of
world-class players actually play a
three and
it's just a coincidence that nobody
tried castles yet they are absolutely
ready to play this position because he 4
doesn't seem to be okay right now so I
think this is a fine line it's a bit
risky but it's not unsound um
of course the main move on the forest is
d5 immediately I'm preventing you form
and on this of course white grabs the
bishop pair with a3 which it takes
you can also retreat but this allows you
for it's a possible line I won't go into
into huge detail here but this seems
fine for white so black takes takes and
now c5 to get some immediate counter
play I know white takes on d5 and black
recaptures with a knight this is played
most often but against weaker players
mostly you also get the recapture of the
pawn and this actually leads to a very
well known structure which is looking
somewhat like this but white is going
for reform
maybe Bishop g5 later to to put out this
pin this is actually position similar or
maybe I even identical I think it's
identical to a classical game of cod
winix roses kappa blanka it's a very
famous game I think from 1919 30s and
it's worth playing over to get an idea
of this structure why this is somewhat
better here um okay 95 some main move
and as the time's running out I'm still
got the limit it's in the next video